a National Dialogue opened in Cameroon
today it's an attempt to end a conflict
in the country's Anglophone provinces
where people want independence now what
you see in blue is Anglophone Cameroon
and that is where most of the English
speakers who account for about a fifth
of Cameron's population of 24 million
people live the rest of Cameroon is
largely french-speaking now the
english-speaking area is actually
divided into two regions called
Northwest and Southwest province the two
provinces are permitted some
self-governance and language rights
including bilingual schools but many
complain of francophone favoured
discrimination in education in the
justice system and in the economy they
took up arms and have been fighting to
establish a breakaway state they call
Amba Sonia
that's the Amazonia flag now the
week-long talks were called by President
Paul Biya who's hoping to end the crisis
that has killed more than 1,500 people
since fighting broke out in 2017 between
the army and the separatists now at the
beginning of September the separatists
imposed a weekly lockdown that saw some
flee the area and it's taking its toll
on those who've remained
gunshots arson and soldiers on the
street residents of the english-speaking
regions in Cameroon have had enough of
the violence and the Monday lockdowns
everyone is affected me too
my car was burned and I was not the only
one all my neighbours in the very first
lockdown
we woke up very early in the morning we
saw all the cars and flames traders in
booya in Cameroon Southwest regions say
they're under relentless pressure to
choose sides if they close shop they
risk being punished by the authorities
but if they stay open they face the
wrath of separatists for ignoring the
call to strike that's created
uncertainty I came to buy a tray of egg
and some foodstuff because of the
lockdown tomorrow you know where we need
to stop in food for today because
tomorrow we may not have where to buy
them
many people here have joined protests
against a marginalization of the
english-speaking regions but their
patience is wearing thin really it is
very bad for 3 years today well be this
offering so really we really need the
peace so we pray that as concerning the
dialogue that is coming we pray that
everything's everything's you move where
so that the peace will reign and then
our countries you come us it was before
Tuesday's unification day but until the
dialogue starts to take effect the
country is more divided than ever let's
go to the capital yeah one day now where
our reporter blazer young is standing by
good to see you blaze so how did the
first day of the national dialogue go on
this first day of the national dialogue
we had many dignitaries including the US
ambassador to Cameron but the most
talked about issue here is that the
separatist leaders did not show up none
of them I mean the big monsters that are
controlling the armed groups on the
ground did not show up and the reason is
that their leaders were already arrested
and brought to Cameroon from Nigeria and
if the government wants to talk to
anyone should be do that in jail I want
to listen to one of the delegates who is
attending the summit and then we'll pick
up from there
so the dialogues address the form of a
stage it's very important that we
discourse on the form of a state that is
the central theme that supposed to be
the central theme of this dialogue
because that's why we went to the
streets that's why the crisis started
that's why people took up arms again the
state so we cannot be here and talk on
other things without talking about the
foremost place missing congas talking
about the forming of his state what does
that mean what that means is that
because Cameron at the moment is a
centralized system and the format of the
studio talking about the federal system
you know governance because when the
British Southern Cameroon's now the
amplifon regions of Cameroon and French
Cameroon came together in effect October
1961 they came together and they agreed
have a federal system but in in 1972 the
den president Amaru Hideo abandoned that
or a unitary government which is today a
centralized system so for people like a
wankum one many applicants who are not
necessarily supporters of a secessionist
movement the belief that the best way or
the mid wave between separatist and the
government is to have a federal system
where they are group own to be able to
control their resources and also
remember that if we could listen to his
talk a bit older when we interviewed him
he talked about that those were the root
cause of this crisis this crisis began
because governments felt like they were
controlled by a francophone so good and
many others what they have been
advocating is that the want of a draw
system okay you mentioned in the
beginning that the tsipras's leaders are
not in attendance but doesn't this
undermine the whole exercise if such key
stakeholders are not taking part a lot
of people that we have spoken here we
have spoken to here believe that this
dialogue itself is not the solution that
believe that this dialogue is a stepping
stone to to the actual solution for the
crisis so a lot of them are hoping that
with this dialogue the government will
be a bit more flexible towards the
opposition and also maybe the the
separatist move of kind of have a sense
that the government is willing to listen
to them so a lot of people see expecting
that some good resolutions will be taken
at the end of the dialogue and then
maybe the separatist come on board
alright that's plays a young in your one
day for us reporting on that national
dialogue thank you